G TO
FENG SENATDI
TFR LONG
UGHT WITSH, G S AN
INE
SENATOR FIRSDE
ENCEPHALITIS AND SAID IT WAS
JUST THE FLU, BU
HAVE ENCEPHALITIS.  THIS I89-YE
TO SERVE ASENATOR.   AL
>> SENOREINSTE. DO YOUL FEE
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOLLS TO
>> THANK YOU I MEAN, THAT'TO
ARYONG TONIGHT>> THERE'S NOTN
GONE FORALONICE, SAS
RETURNED.  SHE'S SAID VERY VERYH
HAPPENED.  BUT, IN THE
REVELATIONHAE DID GET
COMPLICATIONS THATF SHINGLES, S
IT WAS A CAS BLAR NFINHAD BRDE
>> DO YOU HAVE CONFIDENCNTINU
GOOB>> WE'RE A WE
ALL HAVE HEALTH ISSUES. ,
RIGHT W, SHE IS PERFORMING AS TG
HER JOB.
ABILITTO DR JOB? IED ABOUT
>> I N'T ANSWER THAT. IDENCEJ
AND, HER FAMILY'S JUDGMENT.
>>, EST N PERSISD ARS. SHE WASS
EVENTUALHEASIDE BY TOP
DEMOCRATNCWITH HER
BR MEMBER DO AT COULD
HE
N LINE F THE
PRESIDENTIAL SUCCESSION.  SH
TO   POSI
F HE WASING FOR DIANNE FEINSTEI
OFFICE.  NANCY PELOSI'
DAUGHTER, NANC BEE
DOTURNTOEINSTEIN'S SIDE SINCE
RELATIONSHIP, ? WAS AN INTEREST
DEVELOENUTIN RECENHE IS SOMEONE,
HAVE BEEN CLOSE, COMING TH
SAN FRANCISCO POLITICS, THEIR OR
WORKG E TAER IRK HERD ESSENTIAL
SORTS.  SED
POLITICAL QUESTIONS   SI IS M
SCHIFFBE THE NEXNATOR
FROMA TO
HE WOULDLACK WOMAN  RESIGN, E GA
TO THE   HE WOULD DO
THAT THAT MABE UP TH
SENATE RACE, MAKE THE SENATE BIL
DENIES THAT'S THE CASE B THOSE
ARE E QUESTIONSWIRLING.
>> I WAN CHIEF DICAL CORRND
GUPTATA.  LOOK, S BE
THASD THTRY.
AND OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE A N T'S ST
WHICH THEY SAID SHE DIDN'T
T,HE
S COULD ENCEPHALITIS ES IT DO T
ENENGITIS IS AAMMATION OF THR ST
COD BE MRI SCAN OR DO
NCBE RESOLVED AND THE FEVER ANI
BUT, Y BE LEFT WITH
MENTAL CONFUSION
ORY.D SHE'S 89
YEARS-OLSO THAT IS
AMPLIFIED IN SOMEONE
ERIOUS
CONSIDERATION.  NOW,
FICE ISAYING,
WHILE ITESOLVED,AN JID
HUNT S SYNDROM HIS IS A ANOTHER
SHINGLES.  BOT
OF
LES, BASICAL I
HAD CHICKENPA KID,
VIRUS THAT CAUSES CHICKENPOX,
POT N ULT, IS GETS ACVA THAT
YELLOW, SORT OF LINES THATOU T'
SEE ON SOMEONE'S FACE ERCAN AFF
PEOPLE'S FACES CAN B
TT,P  HERAND EYE.E ING ABOUT
HER EYES.  THE LESIONS CAN BE DE
THHA WTHAT, AGINE AT, ERIN, ON O
BUT, I AWHILE.  HO
QUICKLWA DIAGNOSD
COMPAR TPALSY.   SHE OIEOPLOF
WHICH IS SIMILAR
HUNTS SERIIKELY
TO  THANYOER.
>> WELG AS
BRIGHT SELCRWN.  SO,
WHAT DO THN
THINK?N SAN ANCISCO, WHICH
ISFEINSTEIN'S HOMETOWN.    W
SEIN UCTING NORMAL BUSINESS
T HOME
>> AND ANYTHING WE CAN DHELP,
TH WEEK THAT STUNNED
FRANCISCO NATIVE BENTON. >>
SEEMS.
BONTON, AGRESSIVE GRO
LETTER ASKINR  RESIG
FOCU HER HEALTH.  HE HAD
AND WIES
T FEMALE MAYORF
IRST WOMAN
O THE   WE EEDS
ASTORCH.
ANYBODY FEELS IT'S
TO BINT KIND O ENDA U NT.  I ND
ARE OFTEN PRIVATE BL
CHOICE.   I'MNN I WT BE A CAND
RE-EN TO CONESS IN 2022.
IT'SE.
>> THAT' CALIFORNIMAN JACKIEE
RE 2SHE BELIEVES ISACING AN UNF.
DIIT'S AL DECISN    THEERL
RE. >> IS AON TAXPAYERS ARER
>> IF SHE'ING DON'T RE.
>>ERSA TO
SAYS ONE WAY TO FIX THPRIN WASHA
S HA
INCE >> SHOULERE BE AN AGE
LIMIT?
>>
ERE OUUT ONCE WAS.
ALUATION THAER MAKES.
OF PEOTH DIANNE  A L
FEINSTEIN, OR HAVE WORKED FOS C
REPRESENTED BY HER, THEY SAYTHAE